hey guys so I realized I haven't been
that engaged in my social media or my
fan base online over the past couple of
years Ed Sheeran took a bit of a break
but on Wednesday he announced a new
out on the way I'm just living life and
having experiences and I'm open about it
therefore honest being myself Ed makes
the announcement about his long-awaited
new album on Instagram
called subtract and we'll drop May 5th
in the caption he explains how the album
morphed over the past few years saying
he's been working on it for a decade
writing and recording hundreds of songs
with a Clear Vision of how he thought it
should be then at the start of 2022 a
series of events changed my life my
mental health and ultimately the way I
viewed music and art the bad habit
singer reveals Misfortune and tragedy
struck his wife Cherry Seaborn found out
she had a tumor while pregnant with no
route to treatment until after the birth
plus a close friend died suddenly and
then Ed was hit with a copyright
infringement lawsuit forcing him to
defend his integrity and career as a
songwriter I was spiraling through fear
depression and anxiety but the Grammy
winner says writing songs is his therapy
and helps him make sense of his feelings
so Ed got to work and channel that pain
into something positive I just wrote
Whatever tumbled out and in just over a
week I replaced a decades worth of work
with my deepest darkest thoughts I know
I'm in a position now where people know
me and people listen to my music people
come to concerts but like if you strip
it all back and just have me as a
musician as a and a songwriter that's
that's the moment that you look for not
not everything else it's like the real
real moments Ed explains that as an
artist he
record is purely that he says it's
opening the trap door to his soul
for the first time I'm not trying to
craft an album people will like I'm
merely putting something out that's
honest and true to where I am in my
adult life
earlier this month Ed hinted at all that
when he addressed his recent absence
from social media the reason I'm making
this video is uh just being totally
honest I've had some turbulent things
been happening in my personal life so I
just didn't really feel like being
online and pretending to be something
I'm not when I wasn't feeling like that
at the time time he didn't go into
detail about those turbulent things he
mentioned but Ed who's also gearing up
for his mathematics tour returning to
North America for the first time in
nearly five years promised to bring that
good content back to our Instagram the
best thing is I make a living making
people happy which is a wicked thing you
know like I get paid to make someone
smile that's the best job you can have
I'm back online
so um
yeah no
weird it's gonna start being posted here
I made this video like 50 times I'm not
making another one
foreign
thank you